um if your husband was like girl I'm a
successful dude you're doing your thing
uh baby I'm gonna need you to sign a
prenup what kind of hesitancy would you
have for that none you would sign the
prenup I want him
to the punch
you would want to prenup because you
have success in your life or because you
don't want to steal a man's stuff give
it to me from your perspective
um she's Rich all right let's just be
honest that's what it is even before are
like the YouTube stuff my dad does well
so I think like at some point all of the
kids are gonna get a certain amount
um so I I always just assumed I'd have a
prenup to be honest
um but I also think even if I didn't
have that like
I don't know I just think if someone if
if you get to get married and the only
thing you have to do is sign a prenup
what's the big deal okay so then okay
you don't need it well listen
I feel like like I have a friend of mine
that very successful guy
and he wanted to get a prenup do you
know how difficult it was for him to
negotiate this prenup or even bring it
up to his girl he was like he was like
having night tremors thinking about this
right so I guess from your guys
perspective what's the best way to a man
can approach that conversation to be
like babe I love you I want this to work
forever but look at this list of stats
out here divorce stats how should a man
approach asking his wife for a prenup
correct no hopefully this occurs way
before the fiance part this this is how
you do it first you go and you spend
your five hundred dollars for an
attorney's time so you become informed
of what a prenup is so many men we saw
this with a feast when he was on the
show had no idea uh what a prenup is
right so you want to be informed about
what a prenup is what it can do what it
cannot do how it can protect you right
so now you have an idea of what it is
knowledge is power that's exactly right
you know what you want in it right what
do you want in it because if if I
present a prenup to a woman and she's
like okay well what do you want in it
and you're like well I don't know
of course she's going to be skeptical
right if you're going to be the man if
you're going to be the head of the
household and you need to show that that
this this decision that you're making is
informed right so you talking with the
attorney you're going to find out what
you want in the prenup then you're going
to sit your girlfriend not fiance I
swear to God your girlfriend hopefully
this occurs very very soon a way before
the the presentation of the ring and
you're going to say listen
um
we're doing really well we've been
together for a couple of years and
things are going really nice and it
could be uh maybe sooner rather than
later who knows
um I'm going to propose to you because I
love you right you love me I love you
our families are great everything's
great now
um we're gonna have to
marriages marriage is a very important
thing and we're going to have to get a
lot of things in place right we're going
to need Wills right we're going to need
uh powers of attorneys in terms of like
your health care and things like that
what's going to happen if you're
incapacitated what's going to happen if
you die I got you by the way we're
getting right ready yeah ready I'm gonna
help you out save you five minutes of
your life explaining this okay hey girl
you want this ring you have to sign this
thing
well I don't I don't like that
hey
he's like your friend and your friend is
like most men your friend can make a ton
of money on the outside in the outside
world when he gets into the house his
level of disagreeability drops if your
friend was more disagreeable he would
say that what you just said well at the
end of the day comes down to risk are
you willing like if like are you willing
to put your foot down and your risk your
girl getting upset or even leaving you
but I'd rather know that now before I
give you the world 100 like and if
you're like listen babe these are the
[ __ ] rules of the house and if I'm if
we're going to do this and spend the
rest of our lives together this is what
I'm this is what I stand for I mean I'd
rather her fight with me now than after
we get married and we have kids together
and I see how disagreeable she could be
this is like insurance this is your
preventative stuff your way is great in
theory right but I'm trying to I'm
trying to Vacation here bro an
application we're talking we're talking
to men we're talking to a huge swath of
men yeah and so these are the men that
I'm talking to men who are going to have
trouble the man who would do what you're
saying what you say they need to do they
would do that anyway you see what I'm
saying like they don't need you
everybody because they were shout out to
my boss boys out there they're gonna do
that [ __ ] anyway sign this [ __ ] right I
don't know if you're gonna say it like
that but right it's the meaning sign
this [ __ ]
this conversation honestly could take an
hour it can take two hours and some men
say oh well if she if she reacts poorly
then that's an indication that she
doesn't love you or that she's it's not
right for you and that's not true a lot
of times women
women can be insulted by you asking for
a prenup they can think that you think
that that you think that that
that the relationship is not as strong
that as it needs to be or or that you
don't want to protect her you don't love
her so you have to really explain this
stuff to women but then you have to
allow for a period of time for them to
kind of come around to it to absorb it
to to process it right it can't be that
you ask your woman in a great way for a
prenup she says well I don't know about
that and you're like oh well you're not
the one for me right because if she's a
unicorn you want to give her a lot of
Grace you want to understand that she's
a human she might need some all this
over for a few days there's nothing
wrong with that of course but at the end
of the day you have to have the
conversation are you familiar with that
story with the NBA basketball player
Stephen Jackson where the girl kept
delaying I was my second video on
YouTube
she's like yeah we'll deal with that
later we'll deal with that later it got
to the wedding day
he's like she's like they're ready to go
to the Altar and he's like listen I'm
not going to the altar until you sign
this next thing you know like her pastor
shows up like it's like her pastor not
even their pastor and he's like listen
brother
and he's like yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
about it you Pastor Jenkins like I'm not
marrying this lady and basically long
story short I think he spent a half a
million dollars on the wedding whatever
the number was but he didn't go down the
aisle and and now he's like is the lip
tell about at this point
the point that you're saying is this
kind of goes to Ross's point you got to
communicate before you got to
communicate during you got to
communicate after like you always hear
like have you ever asked like couples
what's the key to marriage what's the
key to marriage what's the key to
marriage and it's like we're best
friends we're best friends it's my best
friend I married my best friend but even
more than that is like communication you
have to communicate even in business we
have a theory over here that it's like
not only do you communicate over
communicate hey by the way here's what
is happening today I just want to double
confirm how many times have we talked in
the last two days by the way Pearl
okay and how like we spoke for an hour
we spoke for 20 minutes you spoke when
you didn't know where the hell you were
living and I like got your your Airbnb
I've been through a lot the last four
days the point is it's been a long time
over communicating with you being like
here's what we're doing here's what the
show is and that way you were here we're
having a wonderful show right now
imagine if I didn't even just if I just
kind of barely communicated and I was
like hey yeah I'll see you then it's
like oh I didn't know that the show
started for I thought you wanted me
there before like over communication is
actually a very good thing even in
marriage and sometimes you know the
truth hurts I don't know something I
don't know TLA sometimes you gotta over
communicate I mean sometimes yes but
over communication especially for the
man
I mean
I'm I'm not a fan you know if if you see
over communication for a man can really
put the man behind the eight ball uh a
man can you think if a man is over
communicating
okay give me an example if if a man is
talking about his deepest fears his
insecurities to his no no no no I didn't
say no use that over communicate that is
over communication that's that is that I
wouldn't even say that's communication
that is like revealing too much that's
that's what you want to communicate
that's communication no no you're
conflating two things
I mean it's like you're disgusting
hey by the way wear something nice I'm
picking you up at eight cool by the way
baby uh now it's the day of hey by the
way day today don't worry I won't be
running late I'm communicating with you
I'm not saying I'm not such a hard day I
don't know like that's not where I'm
going I'm fine with communication but
you're talking about over communication
whenever you're saying overview listen
yeah but
right so whenever you go over whenever
you're in excess you start running into
problems that's all I'm saying but
communication is great but for example
you communicated today about the
restroom breaks right right
over communities
everybody it's a two-hour podcast use
the rest
Pearl did you everybody restroom break
we're not having them
call this [ __ ] out because everybody
wants to elevate this whole
communication thing and I see as a
divorce attorney no
that's funny that's funny what time did
you tell me to get here at 3 30. what
time did I get here 3 45 yeah
imagine if I didn't over communicate
that you need to be here at 3 30 I was
like Hey show starts at four right
over communicate boys there it is right
it helped out a lot okay guys
um as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible